hours after the arrival of 80 000 doses
of the johnson and johnson covert 19
vaccine
south africa's president sylla ramaphosa
was one of the first to get the jab
the government says it wants to relay
fears
this day represents a real milestone
for us as south africans that finally
the vaccines
are here and they are being administered
and i was rather pleased that there were
five
people who were vaccinated before me
and they are health workers this
consignment is one of four
expected in the coming weeks the
government says it plans to administer
up to half a million of the single-dose
vaccines as part of a study mainly
targeting healthcare workers
south africa's bought 7 million more
doses for use later in the year
at this vaccine sent in soweto 28
healthcare workers
have registered for their shots only for
nikkei works in the covert 19 ward
at the chris harney barra gwyneth
hospital the whole world has been
crippled by this disease and i see
disease and death with it because of it
every single day
so this is just a step in the right
direction
the johnson and johnson jab has shown
it's almost 60
effective against moderate to severe
illness caused
by a new more contagious variant
identified in south africa
while it's not yet been approved
elsewhere south africa's health products
regulatory authority
has allowed its use for research but
many people
including in the health service remain
skeptical
the reality is that there's very
different levels of understanding
there's obviously a lot of fear
associated with the vaccine
because of the confusion with the
initial one being approved and then
moving on to another vaccine
so staff have been very confused in
february south africa suspended its
planned rollout of the astrazeneca
vaccine a local study had shown it
didn't provide enough protection against
the new variant
once health and essential workers and
the vulnerable are vaccinated
the rollouts expected to be extended to
the general public
and getting everyone on board is where
the government may face
its greatest challenge it hopes to
vaccinate two-thirds of the population
with about 40 million doses of vaccine
to achieve the so-called herd immunity
but it may be many months before south
africa manages
to reach their target family al jazeera